[Música]
nos tomará varios días llegar hasta los
pueblos afectados por la hambruna
Viajando en condiciones extremas porque
el paso de los ciclones vitzirai y
emnati el año pasado y recientemente el
ciclón cheneso destrozaron las
carreteras y aislaron por completo la
región
los cultivos quedaron destruidos y el
transporte de víveres se ha vuelto casi
imposible ayuda humanitaria tardía
inflación el resultado varios cientos de
miles de personas se enfrentan a una
hambruna nunca vista en esta región
fértil
la situación es tan crítica que se ha
cruzado un tabú supremo algunos padres
se han visto obligados a abandonar o
vender a sus hijos hace unos meses una
madre vino a hablar con jossian
cito creaba sola a sus siete hijos y ya
no podía manejar la situación
entonces vino para venderme a su hijo de
11 años le dije eso no se hace y no lo
vendas
si lo trajiste al mundo es porque lo
amas no le hagas esto a un niño es muy
triste me contestó Ya no puedo más Y
prefiero dejártelo le pregunté
le pregunté por cuánto piensas venderlo
me contestó
mil 165 dólares
[Música]
obtuvimos otros testimonios similares
fuera de cámara sin embargo el gobierno
desmiente de manera formal que exista la
venta de niños josean se dio cuenta por
experiencia propia en enero durante la
visita del gobernador de la región
mientras estaba hablando Me
interrumpieron y dijeron que mi
testimonio no era aceptable
dejaron de grabar lo que yo estaba
contando
tres gendarmes estaban filmando
y cuando el gobernador tomó la palabra
dijo que no se podía grabar esa parte
esta bebé fue encontrada en un campo de
arroz con una cuerda alrededor del
cuello tenía tres meses cuando analizó a
se enteró fue inmediatamente a buscarla
para cumplir su sueño de tener una hija
creo que su madre quería matarla
poniéndole la cuerda en el cuello pero
encontraron a la niña a tiempo
su mamá ya no podía alimentarla no tenía
recursos y la abandonó dijo que no
debería abandonarla así pero que ya no
sabía que darle de comer que era lo
mismo dejarla y matarla también dijo que
si encontrábamos a la bebé podíamos
quedarnos con ella porque ella no tenía
nada con que alimentarla y yo no tengo
hijas entonces la cogí
desde que los cultivos quedaron
devastados uno de los pocos alimentos
disponibles son unos tubérculos tóxicos
que producen dolores de estómago Estas
mujeres dedican sus días a excavar la
Tierra en busca de esta raíz
ya no de mandioca no hay nada que comer
por eso trabajo la tierra para encontrar
pico pico
no tuvo más opción que alimentar a su
pequeña hija petricia con pico pico pico
mi hija comienza a planta que se llama
pico pico
y un fruto que se llama aparir por eso
está así
ya no sabíamos que darle por eso le
dimos eso su cabeza ya estaba así antes
pero su cuerpo se volvió muy delgado
esta niña tiene 11 meses pero no come lo
suficiente por eso vinimos acá
el centro de salud básico de Infantería
fue puesto a disposición de médicos Sin
fronteras junto con el personal médico
local examinaron a 6.500 niños y
obtuvieron un resultado alarmante la
tasa de malnutrición severa es tres
veces superior al umbral de emergencia
en total hicimos el diagnóstico y el
total en el distrito dicongo encontramos
una tasa de malnutrición General casi el
20% realmente es un problema de salud
importante
el 20% de los malnutridos en este
Distrito son niños menores de cinco años
según las Naciones Unidas es el lugar
más afectado de todo Madagascar 15% de
la población total está en situación
crítica una cifra más alta que la de los
distritos del Gran Sur afectados Desde
hace dos años por la sequía antes las
personas producían tenían acceso a los
alimentos tenían acceso a los cultivos
Pero ahora con el paso del ciclón
perdieron las cosechas las
infraestructuras están dañadas algunas
familias se encuentran en una situación
tan desesperada que se han acercado a
miembros del equipo de médicos Sin
fronteras ofreciendo venderles un hijo
para poder cubrir las necesidades del
resto de la familia
el programa mundial de alimentos prevé
que 900.000 personas se encuentran en
situación de inseguridad alimentaria
aguda mientras la maldición climática
continúa tras el ciclón chinese en
febrero la región acaba de sufrir El
Paso destructor del ciclón